con un recuento de votos de 337 a favor
y 32 en contra hubo festejo en la cámara
baja del parlamento
los legisladores votaron el jueves a
favor de consagrar el derecho al aborto
en la Constitución Francesa en lo que
podría hacer un cambio histórico para el
país la propuesta fue presentada por el
partido de izquierda a la Francia en su
mesa que señala que la propuesta es para
protegerse de una regresión
[Aplausos]
ese Orgullo y esta emoción son
compartidos por todos hoy porque creo
que con esta votación la asamblea
nacional está hablando al mundo Francia
está enviando una magnífica señal a
todas las mujeres de nuestro país pero
también del mundo entero a los hombres
la votación se registró como reacciona a
los acontecimientos actuales en Estados
Unidos después de que el tribunal
supremo anulará en junio la histórica
sentencia Row contra wave Aunque el
aborto en Francia se despenalizó en 1975
no hay nada en la Constitución que
garantice estos derechos lo que sigue
preocupando a muchos activistas a favor
del aborto
los prohibidos están muy presentes están
organizados a nivel europeo a nivel
mundial en Francia podría ocurrir lo
mismo por supuesto en el contexto
internacional actual invitamos
el aborto podría ser cuestionado aquí
por lo que hay que consagrarlo como un
derecho fundamental
la resolución es el primer paso de un
largo proceso legislativo la propuesta
debe ser aprobada ahora en el senado de
mayoría conservadora e incluso podría
someterse a un referendo a nivel
nacional